at this altitude I can flat-out for my
hands this episode is brought to you by
foodist kitchen sometimes the most
life-changing habits are the ones we put
off of course and learning to cook is at
the top of that list
I only finally took the plunge when
writing the 4-hour chef and it turned my
eating in my life into high definition
that is what I want for you the secret
to learning to cook and enjoying it is
doing so without recipes following
recipes slavishly makes cooking a pain
in the ass it's miserable time-consuming
doesn't have to be this is where foodist
kitchen comes in food is kitchen is a 30
day program that teaches you how to cook
without recipes I highly recommend it
chopping and sauteing or just a small
part of the whole deal you also need to
know what flavors taste good together
what it means to cook until done who
ever knows what that means by the way if
you're novice Buddhist kitchen brings
all these skills together so you can
walk into the kitchen open the fridge
and have an intuitive sense of what to
cook and how to do it it was created by
Daria rose who's a friend of mine one of
my cooking mentors for the 4-hour chef
she's also a neuroscience PhD and
specifically designed this program so
the skills you will learn turn into
habits you will keep and enjoy for life
and she has offered a fifteen dollar
discount off your membership so check it
out Buddhist kitchen that's F ood is T
kitchen calm forward-slash Tim to learn
more about the program and if you
haven't learned how to cook without
recipes you don't know what you're
missing it is awesome
change that today check it out foodist
kitchen dot-com forward slash Tim this
episode is brought to you by XO protein
it's one of the startups that I work
with I love what they do these guys are
making protein bars using cricket
protein powder and before you screw your
face up and look disgusted I bet they
taste better than any protein bar you've
ever had before I devoured these bars
after lifting sessions I take them with
me on the road the recipes were
developed by a three Michelin star chef
former head of R&D at the Fat Duck which
was ranked the number one restaurant in
the world during his tenure the bars are
paleo friendly no gluten
no grains no soy no dairy etc they are
high in protein and flavor and extremely
unique and they do not pop your glycemic
response up oddly enough and you can
look that up on line to see some stories
on that Ferren Stein that's the
journalist who looked at it on top of
all that they are less processed than
nearly all protein bars you'll be able
to find this is your chance to see what
the hype is about the founders were just
on the Forbes 30 under 30 list and they
are offering a deep discount to Tim
Ferriss show listeners if you go to XO
protein com forward slash Tim that's EXO
protein com forward slash Tim today you
can try a sampler pack with all of their
most popular flavors for less than 10
bucks
that's EXO protein comm forward slash
Tim and I would recommend doing it
relatively fast and that's not abs
scarcity thing they're startup with
limited inventory and they sell out all
the time that is what happened last time
I mentioned them so check it out EXO
protein com forward slash Tim hello boys
and girls children and squirrels this is
Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show this is
not one of my normal deconstruction
episodes where I interview someone this
is an in-between Assad but a very very
valuable one I hope it is with Chris
Sacca it was recently the cover story of
the midis issue of forbes magazine he
was on the cover because he is a newly
minted billionaire and the proprietor of
what will likely be the most successful
venture capital fund in history
lowercase one he's an older stage
investor in companies like Twitter uber
Instagram Kickstarter and many more also
where his cowboy shirts has a great
beard and is hilarious and in this
episode he answers all of your most
pressing questions and they were voted
upon and he takes the most popular the
most interesting and gives some
fantastic responses ranging from life
advice to business advice and everything
in between so without further ado please
enjoy this episode with Chris Sacca
how's it going everybody this is Chris
Sacca but because of this microphone and
these headphones and this fancy
podcasting setup that Tim Ferriss made
me go buy so that I could do this update
with you I'm feeling pretty hip-hop
right now if you look at me I think you
know I asked some of you for suggestions
for the name
I like Sir tweets a lot
the unicorn chief aka DJ Sacagawea aka
MC 140 ok sockitumi maybe DJ term
streets cowboy shark MC VC or even Chaka
Khan I think all I think I'll go buy any
of those handles and more in fact at the
end of listening to this if you have
other suggestions for my DJ handle just
put them up on Twitter too at Sacca
meanwhile you guys were very cool to put
up a bunch of questions on reddit
following my discussion with Tim it's
always fun to talk to Tim that
particular discussion was in was in the
midst of my 40th birthday celebration so
we were foggy but having a good time and
I really appreciated the question you
guys put up I am going to try and tackle
a bunch of them Tim asked me to do 5 or
10 but let's see how many we can bang
out before real life responsibilities
catch up to me one of the first
questions I saw was hiring and finding a
good technical co-founder versus
exporting to a mobile web development
company to retain equity you know this
is always challenging this because I
think one of the first questions I get
asked very frequently is where do I find
a good technical co-founder I think you
can just go to where the geeks are
hanging out virtually and physically you
can go to hackathons you can hang out
and github and in hacker news and in
places where geeks are and I think
you'll find that if you're non-technical
yourself you'll find you're actually
more helpful than you probably thought
you were or that you could be I would
encourage you to just not find the
process of finding a technical
co-founder so daunting as much as you
may be envious of their coding skills
they probably have a quiet respect for
the other things at which you can be
helpful the other aspects of the
business as well that said what I've
seen when people outsource their mobile
and web development particularly for a
tech oriented company is it just puts a
glass ceiling on the company you usually
can get a first and a quicker round 1
and round 2 of your product get your MVP
out there but then you're stuck with a
code base that you can't really expand
upon or improve in any way and you end
up tearing it down and starting from the
beginning and so at a time when your
users are most excited and you're most
excited about building something for the
future
you don't really have the tools to
improve it and that's incredibly
frustrating so I think double down get
that technical co-founder right up front
and I think that'll put you in the best
spot the last part of your question
there was about retaining equity don't
be short-sighted about retaining equity
in the early days anyone who is going to
come on and be worthwhile is gonna be
worth a chunk of the company and if
they're not take it back the next
question here if you were to give a
commencement speech tomorrow what would
your message be my first message would
be congratulations to all of you who are
graduating in January now you don't have
to they'll just have a much longer
spring break it'll be great for them
that's it I gave a commencement speech
in Minnesota a few years ago I was
pretty proud of it I think it's probably
you two beable and Tim has a great way
of posting links to these things on a
site but I was at a Carlson School of
Management up at the University of
Minnesota and I will say it was funny
because I actually they they contract me
that speech through my agent we agreed
upon a fee I put a lot of heart and soul
in anytime I've talked publicly and so I
showed up to do this speech and I didn't
realize they actually had me give the
same speech three times to three
different graduations that day it was
intense but I had a really great time
they filled up this hockey arena and
three times I gave a speech and I
actually think I got better I made I
took notes I saw which jokes got no
reaction and gave this speech but the
core of it was to be you're
unapologetically weird self
I think authenticity is one of the most
lacking things out there these days and
that as people strive to all pad their
life their resume and their credentials
we've started to miss out on some of the
fun edge cases that make life
interesting and that make us want to be
around other people and that make us
helpful and valuable and so I spent you
know an hour so going into that stuff so
I would encourage you to go check that
out because I think it holds up now next
question what are the keys to success
for an amazing disco night good good
memory when Tim and I did the podcast
originally it was indeed about to be
disco night on Necker Island we were on
a Richard Branson's island celebrating
my 40th birthday and I gathered a bunch
of great friends and Tim was there and
man it was just a week of really
competitive athletics during the day
intense backgammon and chess matches
debates about the
future of tack lotta heavy drinking and
partying and dancing and you name it
we're lucky to have Richard Branson and
a bunch of fun people there with us what
I found from over my years of going to
parties that I posted or that other
people have hosted if you could bring
one thing to make for an amazing party
night it's wigs seriously go to Amazon
right now and order 50 mullet wigs
mullet wigs change everything I was at a
party recently a good buddy minds
fiftieth birthday party and the the crew
that he had there was a mix of people
some were serious business associates
others were kind of really fun
aggressive party people or some athletes
some artists there were all walks of
life different different cultures - and
I brought a bag of 75 or so mullet wigs
and I just opened it up and I laid them
out on a couch kind of off to one of the
sides of the party it was amazing it
didn't take 15 minutes before people
found their way over there and and I
mean even someone like the stage
financial people one over there found
themselves a mullet wig that they felt
best represented who they are and what
they stood for maybe it was a dog the
Bounty Hunter style maybe it was a real
short long maybe it was just a bandana
that had a rat tail coming down off the
back of it but everyone had an
opportunity to express themselves and
the party just kicked up a notch
it's incredibly inclusive and what
you'll find too is they're even great
for women you know so like a brunette
will put on a blonde mullet wig advice
first so it's fun so the key is you an
amazing disco night because you asked
mullet wigs what are the cases where a
startup should not take investor money I
think started should be very wary of
taking investor money if they haven't
really checked their guts and made sure
that their expectations of what is
considered as success lines up with what
the venture investors expectations of
success are there's this whole category
business is called lifestyle businesses
that you'll hear mention with disdain in
the venture community as if those
companies are some kind of failure so
lifestyle business usually refers to
something that's not growing
particularly fast but it's throwing off
enough cash for the founder and the
employees to live comfortably and nor
it's here but it's not growing 10x a
year over a year it doesn't look like
it's going to go public any time soon so
that's a lifestyle business generally
VCS look down on lifestyle businesses
because they themselves the VCS have
investors whose expectations are huge
RAC stacks of cheddar being passed to
them at the end of the VC fund and so
when a VC puts money into a company that
evolves to become a lifestyle business
that's a bad result for a venture
investor and yet that might be a great
result for you the founder in fact you
guys are all fans of Tim and if you read
Tim's books and follow the people he
highlights many of them have
successfully pulled off lifestyle
businesses work relatively balanced ours
know some you know you generate income
live by the beach have some control of
your own destiny that's great it's kind
of like the definition of American
success but that doesn't necessarily
align with what a lot of investors are
looking for and so I think you shouldn't
take investor money unless you are
confident that you and your investors
define success in the same way which
person would you most like Tim to
interview you know Tim and I talked
about this sometimes and he's approached
me about people he wants to interview
but I have a different take on it I
would like to see Tim interviewed by
somebody else I would like to see Tim
interviewed by God does that work does
this sound like God right now Tim it's
God here it's been a while I haven't
heard much from you since you started
having Sam Harris on the podcast
anyway let's dive in question number 1
your fridge is constantly filled with
your own blood and urine samples yet you
keep praying to me ask me to convince
the perfect girl to settle down with you
drawing any correlations here my little
Tim Tim I think Tim just learned that
there are much deeper costs to having
your friends by their own audio-visual
equipment for your podcast so the
question was who should Tim interview
and I think I want to turn the tables on
that I think Tim is an amazing
interviewer he's got a real
unique perspective on identifying guests
convincing them to come on the show the
kinds of questions he asked them what he
learns from them and translates to all
of us to be able to act on it's unique
in this world Tim really is one of the
best interviewers in media that said
very infrequently does anyone interview
Tim and as a longtime friend of Tim's I
know where some of the bodies are buried
I've been with him through thick and
thin and I think we have some other
fellow friends who do as well and so
what I propose is that we bring back a
panel of interviewers from past episodes
to turn the tables on Tim and put him
under the light and see what we can get
out of him I want to hear what you guys
think about that hit me and and Tim up
on on your socials and let's see if
that's a doable thing one of you asked
what's your best advice for getting down
to business when it's getting tough
whether that be working a late night or
just going for a run so in my mind those
are two really different categories but
I think I might undertake those
challenges differently in my world the
physical challenge always just seems so
surmountable
you can go just get it done it's finite
you go out for a run and you know how
many miles you're gonna run or you run
until you stop running but with more
intellectual pursuits it feels like
there's no finish line there so it's
always really challenging for me because
I feel like I could always be doing more
and I don't always know when something
is done like I do with a physical
challenge I'm even more prone to
distraction when I'm doing something
that's not inherently physical so as a
result if I really want to get some [ __ ]
done
I first focus on the physical space I
want to be out of the way I want to be
clear visual distraction of audio
distraction I usually have some
headphones on even if they're not
actually playing music more about that
in a second I make sure nothing else is
on the desk you know we we have people
who come and look at my workspace and
laugh because there are no papers I got
fax machines out of my life in like two
thousand six or seven or something like
that I just I really don't have things
in the space in which I want to get
something done I create digital space
for myself so I turn off all
notifications we have a company called
rescue time that Tim and I are both
investors and
visors in that has a tool that will just
basically shut off all the other
distractions for you and your desktop
environment but put your phone on do not
disturb you're not going to miss
anything
music-wise sometimes I just wear
headphones without even focusing on
whether there's particularly good music
through them they they send a signal
even a social signal I am not to be
interrupted that said I know a lot of
people put classical music on but I
wouldn't jump to the assumption that
that's what works best for your brain
strangely enough when I was in law
school a dirty little secret of mine
that I ever went to law school and was a
lawyer but I could not sit still through
reading the most boring of books and so
I tried a bunch of different music types
and weirdly what worked for me were
Grateful Dead bootlegs there was
something about them even though they
had lyrics there was something about and
melodically that I could just zone out
that conscious part of my brain and
instead focus on reading the books for
me these days I listened to a
combination of new-age and stuff like
that like Andres Voland veter George
Winston for piano but I also have been
known to put on hip-hop tracks on repeat
and I know that someone's been
discussing the podcast before I Matt
Mullenweg who's a good friend and a guy
whose company I've invested in he
listens to the same track over and over
again when he's coding I do the same
thing when I'm writing even for very
long things I will just have a song on
repeat some of those songs have included
the Harlem shake believe it or not hey I
can bang through an amazing amount of
email with the Harlem shake go on in the
background I listened to that song lifts
off by like J and B and I've just put
that thing on repeat for over and over
again before to get something done I
think I cranked out a few thousand words
with that actually in the background so
who knows but generally what all of this
comes down to is whether you are on
offense or defense and I think that as
you survey the challenges in your lives
it's just which of those did you assign
yourself and which of those are you
doing to please someone else are you out
there actually working off your own
to-do list or are you letting everybody
else write your to-do lists for you via
your inbox and I think being
offense requires more work you have to
do the work of writing down the two dues
of creating the space in which to get it
done of planning the execution of
pushing everything else aside and
prioritizing your work and so I think
before we even get to how you arrange
your physical space and your digital
space and what's in your head and
getting your food and nutrition right
making sure you have a glass water
making sure you've gone to the John I
think the number one thing you can do is
focusing on am i doing this thing for me
or am i doing this thing for someone
else okay you asked if you could move
your family to anywhere in the world and
start fresh what country would you move
to so I don't know about starting fresh
I don't necessarily want to think I I
don't think I necessarily want to start
fresh right now I've got a pretty good
set up that said at multiple points in
my life I've certainly uprooted
everything and moved even when it didn't
make any sense to some of you don't know
this but despite being what people
continually refer to as a Silicon Valley
investor I haven't actually lived in San
Francisco since 2007 I moved to Truckee
California up in Lake Tahoe an amazing
place to live a great place to live but
certainly not a tech hotbed as we think
of it and by that time I really hadn't
made real money in the investing game
and so there I was an aspiring venture
investor moving away from the epicenter
of Silicon Valley to you know a rural
region up in the woods in the mountains
I did that though because as I
referenced earlier I was going on
offense I was sick of doing coffee after
coffee after coffee of just routine
meetings in San Francisco and instead I
wanted to go on offense I wanted to have
the time to focus to to learn the things
I wanted to learn build what I wanted to
build in and really invest in the
relationships that I wanted to grow
rather than just doing a day of coffee
after coffee after coffee and so I moved
up to Lake Tahoe again it on paper it
didn't make any sense at all fast
forward a few years just as things in
Lake Tahoe we're starting to really make
sense
my wife crystal and I I'm like two weeks
notice decided to buy a house in LA and
start splitting our time with Los
Angeles neither of us had ever lived
there before we didn't really have any
business there
all it just felt like the right thing to
do for us and again people read into it
like Oh Chris is endorsing the LA
startup scene or something it wasn't any
bigger than that it was just Cristal and
I decided that that's what made the most
sense for us at that time and so we did
it we made that jump and we love LA but
last year we made another jump to
Montana and we found that there were
some things we wanted to do and to
experience that were in Montana that
weren't in Los Angeles and weren't in
Truckee and so I embody that spirit of
of just picking up and moving my family
you know we have three kids now and so
picking up moving my family and it's an
adventure and it's fun and I think it
teaches them flexibility adaptability it
certainly makes you question how many
things you own because it's hard to move
all your stuff so you end up owning less
stuff but that said I think the thing
that it reminds me of that I'm most
grateful for is how every time I've made
one of those moves I've done it by
choice and I think there are too many
people on this planet right now who
don't have that control over their own
destiny and who are forced to make much
more drastic moves not by their own
choice whether it's unone extremists
Syrian refugee or in the other extreme
someone in the United States who's
losing their house or whose job has been
downsized and I think it's a moment for
reflection that as much as I really
enjoy the culture of lifestyle design
implicit in it has to be some gratitude
that we're fortunate enough to make
these kinds of choices and so you know
ultimately my family will live outside
the country significantly we have three
kids under five right now so letting
everybody grow up a little bit but my
wife grew up all over the world I want
to have that same experience for my kids
too I want them to be exposed to the
human condition I want them to know
people of every color and I want them to
learn other languages and just have that
that broad human experience that I don't
think you can get living in a wealthy
suburb of a major US city Chris in light
of your admiration of Buckminster Fuller
and fascination with sci-fi and musings
about the future what are your thoughts
on how human societies can adapt to the
increasing speed of tech advancement
then there were some other questions
like this how do you see her family's
day-to-day life changing as virtual
reality comes to prominence artificial
intelligence starts replacing a snare a
number of jobs biotech starts changing
our lifespans and we begin to colonize
other planets oh man this just got dark
well first of all of me to say planet
colonization is not a short term concern
of mine the physical limitations of
space travel render it pretty low on the
list for me it's just not gonna come up
for myself maybe my kids grandkids
probably but it's not high on the list
for me unless you know something about
hyperspace I don't know yet so let me
know but I was sitting back on these
other questions that I think are truly
tough questions about the impact of
technology and societal adaptation I am
concerned we approach a lot of this
stuff with this Universal embrace of
progress by with a really engineering
centric focus on what the measures of
progress are when we think about each
year at CES they show a display with
more and more resolution and they show a
virtual reality headset with less and
less latency and their incredible
technical achievements yet what I worry
about is that those displays are
outpacing the rate of our biological and
physiological adaptation years ago
someone gave me a Sony PSP it was
somebody that Sony gave me a PSP and I
was monkeying around without on a flight
and I was playing Grand Theft Auto and
when I got to the airport I got in my
car and started driving and realized I
was driving incredibly aggressively I
was I was a really [ __ ] driver all of
a sudden and it was my brain hadn't
totally distinguished between the
fiction of that game even though again
you know the PSP is tiny screen weird
controls a lot of latency but my brain
this is a neural pathway I've been
created that told my brain that it
confused it was that real or was that
fiction and so when I got to the real
highway I was driving recklessly now I'm
not making an argument for game
censorship etc I'm I don't want to make
this into a bigger discussion that but
the reality is that if you've tried a VR
heads
now you know your brain doesn't really
know what the hell is going on walk up
to the edge and you feel fear you look
down and it's scary
and that's one of the things that's
interesting is that one after one these
advances are technical achievements and
I'm really impressed by the teams that
build these but I don't think we're
making the same investment in the
biological and psychological
ramifications of some of these things
and I don't think it's all bad at all I
I'm an optimist you you asked me a
buckminster fuller and he is the
optimist when it comes to technology he
was the believer that tech could solve
all of our problems he held steadfast
that technological progress would ensure
that the whole planets needs could be
met in terms of food and education
natural resources and yet I and I'm sure
you see a digital divide there haves and
have-nots a healthcare divide an
education divide a criminal justice
divide a nutritional divide and yet much
of the tech available today doesn't seem
to be improving those situations very
much you know I had this interesting
lesson in this years ago when I worked
at Google I was working for Larry and
Sergey and we had an opportunity to
partner with Walmart on a big project it
was related to the wireless stuff we
realized there were about 4,000 or so
Walmart locations in the United States
and if we put a cellular tower on top of
each of them that would have been a
great way to build a wireless network
that was one of the things I was focused
on back then and I once made some
offhand comment about how a partnering
with Walmart would be well that'd be a
dark day for me and Larry and Sergey
that's why what do you mean
I said well you guys are fans of Walmart
and they said yeah it's like the triumph
of efficiency
I mean think of that like think of all
the money that's been saved by
consolidating everything into massive
purchasing power and bringing down costs
throughout the supply chain and central
distribution hubs like that it's an
amazing triumph so they saw as an
engineering and economic exercise and
who can blame them they're one of the
most successful engineering and economic
pairs ever but
you grew up in a small town where the
downtown was replaced by a Walmart out
of the center of town
I saw Walmart as the catalyst for a lot
of American downtown's being abandoned I
saw a lot of people losing their jobs
and their identities and the control
over their own destinies and it was
interesting to be sitting in that room
with them and have those two completely
different perspectives on that company
because of how we'd grown up in what
we've been exposed to and the lens
through which we saw the world and how
we evaluated successful outcomes and so
to bring this back to your question
about the future of technology and
societal adaptation one of the things I
think it's hard for me to do is to put
myself always in the shoes of those who
are going to end up on the wrong end of
these equations one of you asked a
question somewhere who postulated that
it would be something like you know in
the future 30% of us would have a good
and 70 percent of us will have it bad
I actually think on this current path
it's going to be way worse than that
there are we way fewer people who have
it good and the rest will struggle in
the old economy where people used to
have careers and pensions and benefits
that doesn't exist anymore it's been
replaced by people who are called
associates who work hourly who don't
really qualify for benefits who don't
have a safety net and there's scary
implications to that I saw a prophetic
comment recently on Twitter about how
the future will basically be 10
trillionaires and the rest of us will be
taking turns
serving venti espressos to each other
and driving around in each other's ubers
obviously that's intensely dystopian but
there's a trendline pointed in that
direction and yet what I worry about is
that it's hard for those of us who are
even listening to this podcast right now
to parse that because when you think
about your day when you think about your
month in your year and your life up to
this point I like you like to think that
I hustled to get here I can point to all
the times I've worked my ass off but the
reality is apart from just the
advantages of being white and
male in a native English speaker with an
American passport
in my case I was our he's just I was
always just smart as hell I went to
college for math starting in seventh
grade and I've always known that if
there's a system somewhere I'll figure
it out I'll hack it and that's the
challenge is that how do I begin to
perceive the fear and the anxiety and
the hopelessness and even the
helplessness in a system if I just know
in my heart that I will always figure
out a way to come out on top
that's the myopia that concerns me the
most and that's what I think is so
prevalent in Silicon Valley today that
Silicon Valley is populated mostly by
folks who would consider themselves
winners of the traditional race people
who floated to the top of their
educational institutions who've
succeeded in the ranks of their
traditional businesses who have taken
risks entre Nouriel risks and who've had
great success and yet all of that has
come at the exclusion of a lot of the
voices that I consider to be vital in a
worthy society and a round and robust
and exciting Society but they've just
been no it's beyond gentrification
they're just not voices you interact
with much in Silicon Valley today and in
the tech world today and I think that
myopia it concerns me because I I think
it's actually going to end up costing us
as an industry a lot of success but I
also think the lack of of empathy there
is going to lead to more social and
political unrest in this country there's
a really good shot at unravels I mean
I'll just say you know this leads into
one of you asked a question it says
Chris you recommended two books on the
first podcast how to make millions and
rising Asia and how did and then the
other books called not fade away both to
cultivate a more empathetic perspective
why empathy and what got you there and
what is everyone missing
I think I touched on a lot of that
already but you know as a builder as an
entrepreneur how can you build something
for someone else if you don't have even
enough glancing familiarity with them to
imagine the world through their eyes how
can you define the feature set how can
you think about pricing I mean I might
not care about I don't care about a $4
99-cent app installed but almost
everyone on the planet does how can you
build something with identity and heart
you're building it for an audience you
don't really know sometimes you can luck
into it and sometimes audiences have
problems they themselves don't
understand but there is an incredible
amount of empathy I think missing in the
system today and I think you don't have
to look far to understand why there's so
much political discord particularly when
you you know I think those of us in tech
tend to either be progressive or
libertarian but generally within the
tech world there's been a lot of
animosity toward those in the extreme
right the anti science right and yeah I
don't think you have to look hard to
understand where that comes from
you've got a huge group of people in the
United States who have basically lost
the control over their own destiny the
small businesses they used to run and
have gone away they've lost their farms
they've lost their houses they've lost
the ability to plot their own future
when they get up in the morning
committed to work hard they don't
necessarily know that it's gonna work
out for them if that were you you'd
probably be looking for scapegoats too
now I think some of those scapegoats are
missing laced and the blame isn't laid
in the right place but underlying that
there was a certain amount of empathy
and part of that's because I've gone and
spent time with those people and tried
to understand their plight and I think
those of us who will take that time
invest in that understanding our lives
will be richer for it our societies
would be stronger for it our kids will
be better for it and I think our
products and the services we offer will
actually play out a lot better as well
is that a long enough answer for you
Chris if you were to start your own
school to educate youth how would you do
it what would you concentrate on how
much would you pay the teachers is
education the answer to the world's
problems presuppose
that you weren't using schools to just
train your kid to be successful with air
quotes around it think about how the
purpose of Education up to this point
has always been well if you do well in
school you can get into a great college
hitting a great college maybe you'll get
into a great grad school and then you
can get a great job and that has been
the basically baseline underlying
assumption for our education system for
at least a generation now probably too
and yet imagine if that weren't the case
I mean I was lucky I went to the School
Foreign Service at Georgetown one the
most competitive schools in the country
and among my peers were kids who went to
all the fanciest boarding schools all
the best prep schools all the best high
schools I went to a public high school I
went there with absolute trepidation
that I would just get trampled by these
kids and while their life experiences
are certainly more diverse and exciting
than mine because they had the money to
do all kinds of cool things and they had
AP classes and stuff that I didn't
necessarily have spending time with them
I realized that their worldviews were
incredibly narrow most of them had never
worked or lived among poor people most
of them hadn't actually volunteered
most of them hadn't had service jobs
tipping jobs they hadn't worked manual
labor same went on when I worked out in
Silicon Valley with top Harvard and
Stanford grads at Google and beyond all
across the valley same kind of thing I
found people who were incredibly
successful with those air quotes and yet
had very you know dimensional lives and
so back to your question if I were to
start my own school what if you started
a school that presupposed the goal was
happy kids and I mean happy with a
capital H balanced thoughtful and
passionate doers what if their resume
wouldn't ever matter some of you ever
heard me say before that the only people
who care about your GPA are people who
you've given no other basis to evaluate
you so what if instead you wanted to
build an education that fostered
interestingness understanding action
experience
school looks like but
how my wife crystal and I have been
approaching raising our three daughters
I've yet to see test scores correlate
with happiness
I've yet to even see test scores
correlate with learning with a capital L
and so I don't know what I would do to
reinvent the education system or any
particular school but it's certainly top
of mind for me one of you asked can you
elaborate on the Ironman you completed
in 2008 what real-world transferable
lessons did you learn so the Ironman I
did I actually did two of them by weeks
apart one was just a training session
where I realized there was gonna be so
much training that day I was like [ __ ]
it let's just do the whole Ironman and
then I did a formal sanctioned Ironman a
few weeks later I had a phrase I kept
repeating in my head over and over again
which was tonight I will be in my bed
tonight I will be in my bed tonight I'll
be in my bed and it was something I just
repeated that to remind me that the pain
of what I was going through was
temporary and that no matter what at the
end of that day I would be in my bed
that night in 2009 I rode my bike across
the country it was a forty day trip with
thirty five days of riding incredibly
intense almost 100 miles a day and I
hadn't trained for it at all a friend of
mine gave me the trip about two weeks
before it left and so I showed up to the
West Coast muffin-topping out of my my
like route bike shorts I couldn't name
any of the parts of my bike I just
bought a bike actually I didn't even
have a road bike at the time I agreed to
do it I'd given away my tri bike but I
used the same principle there during one
of most painful experience in my life
just every time I would just say tonight
I'll be in my bed and so I don't know if
you can translate that to everything you
do in the real world but try it someone
asked are you more inclined to invest in
a founder who has a proven
entrepreneurial track record or someone
who's a first-time founder but a
seasoned professional with relevant
expertise in the area they'll be
competing I really worry expertise can
be a contra indicator think about the
uber founders Travis Garrett Ryan
none of them had had ever driven calves
before or limos and what I think I found
is that experience often deeply embeds
the assumptions that need to be
questioned in the first place when you
have experience of something you don't
notice the things that are new about it
you don't notice the idiosyncrasies that
need to be tweaked you don't notice
where the air gaps are one of the things
I've always admired about Evan Williams
as an entrepreneur is his ability to see
the assumptions that the rest of us are
taking for granted on the other hand I
don't always think track records play
out I do not automatically back someone
who's just had who had a great first
exit I don't think that's necessarily
determinate surely there are founders
who want to show us that time and again
they are capable of building cool stuff
but often what happens is you'll see
that second time founder malaise where
if they've already exited they might not
have that same fire in their belly you
have to test those assumptions too they
may keep making every decision based
upon what they did the last time around
even though there's new facts this time
they may try and pattern match and that
can be distracting so be careful about
that next question was Chris I know it's
a tired subject and hopefully one day we
won't have to talk about anymore
but what are some of the ways that VCS
can bring more diversity to their firms
and more diversity to their portfolios
women and people of color are
underrepresented on both sides of the
table truth is it doesn't really matter
what you're doing a diversity of thought
is good for business why the reluctance
from VC well I'm glad you brought it up
it's not a tired subject and it's not
going to get better unless we talk about
it and I'm glad I'm glad there's
awareness I'm glad people are talking
about it but here's one thing that I
think is going to end up fixing it in
the end for us it's greed
the reality is that these
underrepresented talents women and
people of color and LGBTQ community one
of the interesting things about this is
that they all represent huge communities
of disposable income with unique product
desires with the unique tastes these are
huge economies that have largely been
ignored and so what happens is Silicon
Valley has invested in the things that
understands and the things that white
guys get to the chagrin of these other
founders and as a result they've missed
big markets I mean we get credit for
being early style seed investors and yet
what was funny was we invested in style
seed because we liked melody and we
thought she had some hustle I had no
idea how big that market was until my
wife crystal explain to me how big that
market was and how much women actually
spent on their hair and then later when
I checked back in with melody I learned
how much african-american women spend on
their hair and as a percentage of
disposable income it was huge and I
started to learn about this huge huge
economy and so I put more money in the
company and then I took her out to help
tell the story up and down Sand Hill
Road and she was ignored because most
white guys don't pay more than 20 bucks
to get their hair cut and so they have
no idea what it costs to get a color
what it costs to get a weave what it
cost to get a digital perm if you have
Asian hair no idea and so it turns out
that's an incredibly successful company
going after a huge market and now there
are a lot of white guys who are figuring
that out and the company succeeded as a
result of having you know it's led by a
woman who's incredibly successful leader
with a dynamic management team of women
and it's going to be a success story and
I think the next time people get
approached with a deal like that they're
gonna remember that a similar company
that we have old in venture it's
absolutely revolutionizing how credit
works in a mobile environment
particularly in developing world led by
a woman named Shivani Surya
Shivani would be easy to underestimate
and I'll bring up just her physical
stature by way of this prejudice but
she's like a short Indian woman and it
would be easy in the traditional big
glad-handing white guy venture capital
world to just walk past her and say like
she can't be up to anything incredible
and and if I were in a room looking for
who I was whose company I was going to
invest in I probably would have ignored
her the circumstance about which we met
or I I was seated next to her to dinner
and I asked her what she was up to and
two and a half hours later I realize I
hadn't taken a bite at my food because
she pitched me what she was working on
it was so amazing I would just I was
incredibly engrossed I couldn't
stop talking to her about it ultimately
I became a partner in her business and
yet I saw as she went and told her story
to other investors I really do think
they judged her by the cover and didn't
take her seriously as one of the most
aggressive ambitious savvy and
successful entrepreneurs I've ever
worked with in venture will be a huge
company and it'll be thanks to Shivani
who not only founded herself but taught
herself to code and yet I I was as
guilty as anybody I I really think
initially I was judging the book by the
cover and I wouldn't have given it the
time of day unless we'd been forced to
sit next to each other and so I
encourage everyone to keep building
diversity and inclusion programs to keep
putting time into these efforts and
talking about the subject because it's
glaring and the extent to which we're
seeing these communities
underrepresented it frankly just makes
for more boring and starched environment
I love going to in venture for the board
meetings and you can see if you go to in
venture inv ent ure and look at their
about page and who works at the company
you'll see it's the most ethnically
diverse company maybe in the in our
entire industry I have the most fun when
I go to their offices I think it's the
most collegial and exciting and happy
place I've ever been to I think it
correlates and so when you've got just a
bunch of white guys all hang out with
each other I don't think it's it's fun I
don't think this is rewarding so
hopefully this will continue to get
better but I I just want to acknowledge
the fact that I think greed will play a
role
helping straight that out where can I
get some of those sweet shirts Scully is
my brand I buy them direct from the
company now well they send them to me
but vintage western wear comm is a good
place to go look for all of them if
working in a start-up environment what
should one do or focus on to learn and
improve as much as possible I think you
should go to all the meetings you can
even the ones you're not invited to and
figure out how to be helpful if people
wonder why you're there just start
taking notes read it all the other notes
you can find in the company and gain a
generalist knowledge that you're very
limited job function may not offer you
one day and just make yourself useful
and helpful by doing so that's worked
for me in a few different environments
and I encourage you to try it Chris
what's next for you down the road a bit
will you grow bored with the current VC
path will it fascinate for decades what
would you be doing if you decide to stop
investing well it's not about getting
bored solving problems and competing to
make things better is always fun and if
you don't agree with that this is
definitely not the business for you
should gut check on that but has said
the current VC path for me can be
frustrating one of the hardest things as
an investor is having so much time
energy money passion and even identity
wrapped up in a company that you don't
actually run
it's exhausting to not be able to make
those decisions and yet to have so much
at stake plus as these companies get
bigger and bigger yes it means bigger
dollars more money potentially to be
made but it also means bigger egos or
politics more pissing matches or
backstabbing I realized all this a few
years ago and I realized the cost it was
wish it was coming for me I wasn't
sleeping very well as gaining weight I
wasn't getting the exercise I wanted to
I had high anxiety so I actually brought
on a partner Matt Mazzio Matt not only
helped re-energize me a bit but he was a
fantastic partner and really taught me
some things about investing and about
the companies that we're gonna be
successful and so a little over a year
ago Matt took over our funds day-to-day
and I became the chairman of lower case
so so I actually have step back from the
VC path and the path that that built the
business I'm gonna still work on lower
case every day but Matt runs our funds
in place of that I have three kids now I
have an amazing wife
I'm really close to my parents home
close to I have been there to help my
wife on her creative projects just
basically a support role on these
incredible scratch-and-sniff wine and
whiskey books she's written we've worked
with partners on restaurants nonprofit
work I've tried to focus on getting back
in shape that was hampered by shoulder
reconstruction I just had to do let me
know by the way if you know any die
gurus with a favorite you know
nutritional regime
I don't know I'm out there looking for
somebody but at the end of the day
trying to be away from startups is an
exercise in futility I think for me and
that that leads me to Shark Tank you
know this this season I'm on Shark Tank
for a few episodes and a lot of people
who ask me why is someone who stepped
back from the day-to-day of my firm and
I think what I realized is that Shark
Tank brought me back to what made me
passionate about startups in the first
place it brought me back to a few
founders with a great idea with a
product in hand with early traction and
they want somebody to come on board and
help them and that's something that
really AHS at the core of who I think I
am I get excited by those ideas I get
excited by that
early traction and trying to parse which
ones are gonna work and which ones
aren't I'm thrilled by the opportunity
to be helpful and have a stake in the
upside when it all works out I love
putting my money where my mouth is and I
love staking my own brand and energy and
reputation on these projects and the
stage of companies that come to Shark
Tank are they're raw they're edge team
they're so early still it just reminds
me of my very first days of angel
investing when we would sit down at a
coffee table at the brick house cafe in
soma San Francisco and and I would just
get so thrilled and I missed that over
the years as the business got bigger and
bigger and there are more and more
lawyers involved or more accountants and
tax people and regulators and filings
back office folks I just started to lose
touch with what was exciting about this
business and so it's one of the reasons
why I'm absolutely thrilled to be on the
show right now
and I think you'll you'll get more and
more of that energy for me as a as the
show goes on as the season goes on
anyway thank you everybody for having me
back it's always fun to talk about Tim
Ferriss behind his back let's keep this
going out on the web more than anyone
else on the Internet
I love you guys and gals as a tribe
you're insane Tim and I talk about this
a lot you are savvy curious you're
pragmatic you're cheap is how you're
ambitious you're motivated you're highly
engaged and yet you're not as crazy as
one might think you'd be on paper a lot
of people I think would jump to the
conclusion that Tim's devotees must be
all crackpots a few of you definitely
are but most of you are just really
amazing people and so I enjoy hearing
from you I'm at sac on Twitter at sac on
periscope and C Sokka on snapchat and
last let me just say I'm on Shark Tank
this Friday the 15th of January at 9
p.m. Eastern and Pacific and I've got
something to say during those time slots
on your calendar and schedule a vitally
important meeting with me do it at my
email address see Sokka
CSAC CA @ gmail.com I'll accept your
meeting and we can have a one-on-one
particularly if you give it a name that
makes it sound like the fate of the
world is riding on it a few hundred
people have done this already and are
getting a kick out of it so give it a
try
this Friday shark tank at nine let's
watch it together I'm sure I'll be on
periscope and we can live watch it
together
alright everyone thank you so much this
has been fun this episode is brought to
you by XO protein it's one of the
startups that I work with I love what
they do these guys are making protein
bars using cricket
protein powder and before you screw your
face up and look disgusted I bet they
taste better than any protein bar you've
ever had before I devoured these bars
after lifting sessions I take them with
me on the road the recipes were
developed by a three Michelin star chef
former head of R&D at the Fat Duck which
was ranked the number one restaurant in
the world during his tenure the bars are
paleo friendly no gluten no grains no
soy no dairy etc they are high in
protein and flavor and extremely unique
and they do not pop your glycemic
response up oddly and
and you can look that up on line to see
some stories on that Ferren Stein that's
the journalist who looked at it on top
of all that they are less processed than
nearly all protein bars you'll be able
to find this is your chance to see what
the hype is about the founders were just
on the Forbes 30 under 30 list and they
are offering a deep discount to Tim
Ferriss show listeners if you go to XO
protein com forward slash Tim that's EXO
protein com forward slash Tim today you
can try a sampler pack with all of their
most popular flavors for less than 10
bucks that's EXO protein com forward
slash Tim and I would recommend doing it
relatively fast and that's not abs
scarcity thing there start up with
limited inventory and they sell out all
the time that is what happened last time
I mentioned them so check it out EXO
protein com forward slash Tim this
episode is brought to you by foodist
kitchen sometimes the most life-changing
habits are the ones we put off of course
and learning to cook is at the top of
that list
I only finally took the plunge when
writing the 4-hour chef and it turned my
eating in my life into high definition
that is what I want for you the secret
to learning to cook and enjoying it is
doing so without recipes following
recipes slavishly makes cooking a pain
in the ass it's miserable time-consuming
doesn't have to be this is where foodist
kitchen comes in food is kitchen is a 30
day program that teaches you how to cook
without recipes I highly recommend it
chopping and sauteing or just a small
part of the whole deal you also need to
know what flavors taste good together
what it means to cook until done who
ever knows what that means by the way
from novice Buddhist kitchen brings all
these skills together so that you can
walk into the kitchen open the fridge
and have an intuitive sense of what to
cook and how to do it it was created by
daria Rose who's a friend of mine one of
my cooking mentors for the 4-hour chef
she's also neuroscience PhD and
specifically designed this program so
the skills you will learn turn into
habits you will keep and enjoy for life
and she has offered a $15 discount off
your membership so check it out Buddhist
kitchen that's F ood ist Kitchen calm
forward-slash Tim to learn more about
the program and if you haven't learned
how to cook without recipes you don't
know what you're missing it is awesome
change that today check it out Buddhist
kitchen calm /eto
if you want more of the tim ferriss show
you can subscribe to the podcast on
itunes or goto for our blog calm calm
where you'll find an award-winning blog
tons of audio and video interview
stories with people like Warren Buffett
and Mike Shinoda from Lincoln Park the
books plus much much more follow tim on
twitter at twitter.com/dspacestv
or on facebook at facebook.com slash Tim
Ferriss until next time thanks for
listening